it was Richie sinak's second outing at
the dispatch box and this time labor had
more ammunition after a week that's been
focused on chaos in the immigration
system every one of kirst Armor's six
questions while the government's record
on tackling migration his Home Secretary
says the Asylum system is broken
who broke it the number of people
deported to Rwanda is zero since then 30
000 people have crossed the channel in
small bloat it's not working so why
doesn't he get a proper Home Secretary
scrap the Rwanda gimmick crack down on
smuggling gangs in the Small Boat
Crossings speed up Asylum claims and
agree an international deal start
governing for once and get a grid even
some Tories have privately conceded
secure's tactics were effective he even
forced this admission from Rishi sinak
of all the people who arrived in small
boats last year how many Asylum claims
have been processed not enough is the
answer very straightforward not enough
and that's what we're going to fix and
so Rishi sunak reached for old attack
lines falling back once again on
secure's predecessor
the team told the BBC and I quote I do
think Jeremy corbyn would make a great
prime minister
he may want to forget about it but we
will remind him of it every week because
there's the conservative government that
will keep this country safe
a spokesperson for labor said after that
Corbin bars make the pm look desperate
and the public know the party's changed
as for the embattled Home Secretary last
week under attack she barely flinched
this week's swella bravement was
animated visibly defending herself her
expression said it all
and the tough questions came too from
the blue benches including this from a
keen Boris backer prime minister during
the summer you set out a comprehensive
10-point plan to tackle this issue
everybody on this side of the chamber
wants you to succeed in this aim when
can we expect the firm action the
British people
and pmqs couldn't pass without reference
to Matt Hancock's Venture into reality
TV could he also recognize the value
that our trade deals are doing in
allowing us to export our high quality
produce around the world in particular
the Australia agreement where a member
of this house will be able to enjoy a
certain delicate cut in his Bush tracker
top tiles
it drew a laugh from the PM but no
comment on Mr Hancock's decision as a
man helping Mr sunak prep for pmqs
watched on it was an assured performance
from the new prime minister but attacks
on the conservative record on
immigration are hard to defend for a
party who've been in power for 12 years
week two and Rashid sunak's problems are
piling up